what is your first step in writing a
screenplay I mean how much time are you
spending developing the character are
you developing the idea first character
second how does it work I think it all
happened sort of organically and it does
take a long time you know I think you
know you just there's little ideas
percolating around all the time and you
think okay well maybe that could be
interesting and you start writing some
stuff and developing and sometimes you
find you flush it out is just not that
it's not gonna engage you for a foul and
sometimes you just plain this little
germ of an idea you know and it can just
be you know a single thought or a little
you know some little thing you know or a
person or whatever and one little thing
and then it starts to just like pull
things together you know you start to
see that with the resonances of
different things I really love that
approach to writing a screenplay you
know that it's really it's an act of
curiosity and discovery I feel like when
you write a screenplay it's like being
an archaeologist you're excavating
something that already exists somehow
and I think that sort of organic path
for me is definitely the way that bears
the most fruit when I try to be clever
or try to do it in a more strategic way
I think the the results are less
interesting but when it just comes you
know my second film is about a yoga
teacher who is meets her biological
sister for the first time houses houses
for the first time as an adult and her
half sisters a sex worker I mean for me
like this came partly like I was working
in a I was doing some volunteering in a
homeless shelter and I talked to this
woman and it was and she told me this
story and it you know it was just
something about her and this story about
being rescued that really read you know
just like it got me you know and I
started think about just people from
different walks of life and for me I've
worked as a yoga teacher and I actually
taught in a social welfare Center for
prostitutes for awhile and that had
really made an impression on me and I
thought about I mean a lot about those
women and the violence with which they
lived and you know how does someone help
them and you know it's when you start
like just pulling things together that
you're in
and it starts to make its own shape and
I feel like you can't force that phase
it's sort of like having a baby it just
grows by itself in your belly for quite
a long time before you give birth and I
think writing a screenplay is like that
you know you have to allow yourself that
gestation period you know where you're
just you know letting things percolate
and letting yourself like just wander
and letting yourself be open to what
might be around the corner that could be
the thing that you know they explained
something I feel like it's a you know
it's just it's a journey you know
writing a screenplay
it's a journey you're discovering this
thing and you just want to be really
open to what it could be
and and enjoy it certainly doing
absolutely it also happened in a really
organic way I had certain ideas but then
when we went out to the desert it was
sort of like oh it just suddenly made
sense this is a road movie you know it's
a road movie about two people going to
this place that's really what the earth
is gonna look like in the future you
know and they're obsessed with that I I
feel like as a screenwriter I often see
this kind of advice to screenwriters
which goes something like you know read
the trades and and see what's selling
and you know and then write something
like that and study other screenplays
and I think good god you know I mean I
think reading a lot of books is very
important I think reading watching tons
of movies is super important reading
some screenplay so you understand the
format and the craft but then like
allowing yourself the space to really go
off the reservation you know and just
allowing it to form in its own way
because the first draft is really I mean
it's just the start of a very long
journey you're gonna rewrite your script
at least 20 times before you shoot you
know I I don't I've never heard of
anyone that does laughs in probably 20
drafts from a first script shooting
script you know if they do I'd love to
meet them but I think most people it's
it's like it's a you know it's a process
you know and your first draft you just
want to make yourself as free as you can
and as honest as you can and as curious
as you can and let things unfold and
that will I think that gives you the
best chance of writing something that's
gonna be you know engaging and unique
but you've said there's been times when
you've abandoned ideas that they just
weren't yeah you weren't as obsessed
with them maybe as you would have liked
and what point do you usually know that
or add I'm sure it varies but how do you
know that you know not told well just
when you feel it you just feel it's just
like the fit you know like that look
that you just gave it's like you just
feel like you're just not that interest
but you start something and then three
days later you're not interested I mean
I do have a thing when I'm writing a
first draft where I generally say I
write four to five pages a day once I
once I start to write the script
you know like four I'll let myself have
months of just like pulling things
together he'll know and I'm always
buying books that are connected to
whatever it is and watching films you
know just like just filling up all them
well in a sense and then I reach a
certain point where I'm like I'm ready
to write the script you know and and
then I'm totally strict about just you
know I'll set myself like four pages a
day or five P Tuesday and that is it
like there's no excuse you know if it
takes you all day takes all day if it
takes an hour it takes an hour but
that's the minimum you're gonna write
every day then I get the script done
that way and you know I think like when
you're in that poses like somewhere
usually before you actually start
writing a script he's just not like it's
just if it's if it's not that
interesting you to you the resonances
aren't there if you're having to force
it you know at this stage then I feel
like abandon it a bit JumpShip no
because at that stage of gestation and
leading up to writing your first draft
if it's not holding you then it's it's
not gonna hold you you know and maybe it
will come to you later you know I have
had that experience and I think actually
my second film is is it was a little
like that cuz I think it had the idea
park I've had it for years percolating
you know the idea of a yoga teacher and
a sex worker then this relationship
between them you know and so it was
something but I couldn't really find it
I couldn't really crack it before and
then suddenly it was like oh yeah I get
it they're sisters you know and
different things you know came into that
so you know I think sometimes if you do
have a good idea but it's not quite
working out you're having to force it
and you're pushing through it you know
sometimes the best thing is just to
leave it set aside working something
else and then maybe it's a year later
two years later three years later you
come back to you go now I know what that
needs you know and and it can go again
you